- Maybe she saw your
pubes once and she's like,
"all I see are Jimmy's pubes."
- Yeah.
That sounds like what
a principal would say.
(upbeat music)
- Hey guys,welcome to
The Other Show again.
My name is Chris.
- I'm Sarah.
- And we're here with
Drew and Heléne, and Jimmy
and Navaris who play a
couple of the Insta Gays
in this episode.
(loud cheering)
- We're very excited
for this episode to air
and to shoot this episode
'cause it really made us laugh,
and you guys are
so funny in this.
- Thank you.
- Those characters that
are bitchy gay guys is such
a stereotype, so to play
someone who's, they have no...
they're just really kind.
- Yeah
- Oh no, totally, yeah.
- Drew's the villain.
- It was so great
that my character's
- Drew's the absolute villain.
- the villain.
- It's so, it was so refreshing
to be like, 'Yeah their not
bad, I am bad.'
- Yeah
(laughter)
- I'm using them.
- All you do it get
naked and post pictures
and have sex with each other.
- We don't have sex
with each other.
- What? Why don't you?
- I had to go through and
unfollow a bunch of these guys
because I would just
like, be out in the world,
and I would be technically
looking at porn.
(laughter)
- Oh yeah!
- Because I'd be like
hiding my phone like
over in the corner.
And I was like, I can't just
be looking at a man's full butt
at the doctor's
office waiting room.
- But it happens suddenly
enough where you follow one,
then two, and then
- Yes!
in a year you're like
this is porn I'm
scrolling through.
- He said when we would
like researching-ish
the Insta-Gay culture, any
profile I went to was like,
followed by Drew Darker.
(loud laughter)
- Are you Brooke?
- Wow!
- I was wondering
about the model.
- Oh, my god!
- Oh, in Madison Square Park.
- Yes, I'll talk about it,
you see beautiful people
like that in person,
and it's like truly shocking.
- It was shocking
when I watched it.
- Like a drawing, he
looks like a drawing
- He looks like a drawing,
it's unbelievable to me,
I feel like I wanted to ask him
but I didn't quite
know how to phrase it,
like what is it like
to look like you?
- I was mad at you.
- Like how has that been?
- But he would have killed her
though, like clearly like...
Who shows up like,
- Yeah, like 100%
in the middle of the day?
- That was the original joke!
He was originally going to say,
"Now I have to find
someone else to kill."
(laughter)
- How come you guys cut it?
- I dunno, we liked
him being like,
- I liked a very
handsome man saying,
'I'm a loser.'
- left in an existential
crisis.
- That was actually
one of my favorite
things to shoot as well because
we shot that in
Madison Square Park,
like in the early,
early morning,
and shooting in New York
City in like, iconic areas
like that in the
morning, they're empty
and you sort of watch
the city come alive
while you're standing there,
and it's really amazing.
Let's see that body.
Wait, where's the body.
- This is sort of an
embarrassing thing,
but maybe it will
spark something,
but you go on a
date with that guy,
Paul, from Rolling
Stone, but we were like,
oh what's a good douchey Twitter
handle for a guy like this,
and we used my real
one from high school
because it was so douchey.
My AIM screen-name,
in high school
was King of Sarcasm Zero-One
(laughter)
- That's me!
- No, it's not!
I must have been thinking like,
I am pretty sarcastic.
(laughter)
In fact, I'm the king of it.
- I had just ended a
production of West Side Story,
and I was Baby John, so my
screen was Baby John Five.
(laughing)
Isn't that just like...
- That's okay.
- It's sad, you
do one production
- You were proud of that
production and that performance!
- It's so embarrassing,
like Baby John--
- It's very literal to
be like, I was Baby John,
my screen-name
should be Baby John.
- Well yeah, it is kind of like
when you are in high school,
like one thing you've done,
you make your
entire personality.
- It's a big deal!
- Yeah.
- Oh, as a matter of
fact, I was a big deal
in West Side Story, and
it wasn't my screen-name,
but my class ring says,
"A Big Deal," on it.
- Oh no!
- Whoa, that's good!
- Wow, West Side
Story ****ed us up.
(laughter)
- I'm sorry!
- Mine was Belleoftheball,
because of a Guster song,
where that is a
lyric, 103, which is
where in the song, that
lyric first appears,
- Whoa...
- But the Belle was
spelled with an E,
because that was my
favorite Disney princess.
- That's rough.
- Oh my...
- Isn't that just like,
layers of sadness?
- There's so many layers.
- Huh!
- Honestly though if I known,
- This is so earnest.
- Sarah in in high school,
I would have been like,
you are deep girl,
I wanna be like you.
- Mine, was complicated.
(chuckling)
because I'm a big X-Men fan.
- Okay.
- So I wanted an X
in it, and my mom
had a porcelain
figure of a swan,
(laughing)
- Oh, God.
- I looked to like, the
left, and it was there,
so I was like, Swanex,
and it was like,
(chuckling)
S W A N E X, and it
sounds like a cleaner
that you would like, use.
- Wait, S W A N E X?
- Yeah, S W A N E X,
and it was like, Swanex.
- You did, like, what they
do in bad writing in comedy,
then they're like, my name
is Bob Treestonefloor.
(laughter)
- Let's do like, a funny one.
- Oh yeah, okay good, yeah.
- Yeah!
- Okay, and...
- Good.
- Three, two, one.
(shutter clicking)
- Wait, how did you guys pose?
- So we asked you
guys to show us
pictures that you had
posted on the internet,
where you were being thirsty.
Okay, this is Navaris.
- That is good!
- Oh, wow!
- Is this your hair?
- That is good!
- Yeah, that was
me in like, 2016.
- Wow!
- We were like, send
the picture that's like,
we can kind of like, laugh about
'cause you're just
too thirsty in it,
and we got this
and we were like...
- No, that's fine, he
should post it, that's good.
(laughter)
- That's just not good...
- I would love to see
that on my scroll.
- I'm really repressed, I think,
(laughing)
but I still want
to participate, I'm like, okay
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- Yeah!
We asked Drew for
a thirsty photo,
and it's him as a speck!
(laughing)
You have to zoom in
so much to see any body.
- But that's what you said.
- Yeah!
- You were like, if someone's
going to "work for it,"
- Yeah!
- Then they're gonna
get the reward.
- If they really zoom in,
- Work for it.
- you will see a blurry,
kind-of-good chest.
(chuckling)
- Let's show Jimmy's.
- Okay, Jimmy's is good.
- This is also good.
- Whoa!
(Acclaimation)
- How did you get that?
(laughing)
I'm freaking out.
- This is like, Justin Thoroux!
And by the way, when you
post a thirsty photo,
your thirst gets quenched!
(chuckling)
People like that shit!
(laughing)
- That's why people do it,
- Yeah!
- I know it works!
- I know!
(upbeat music)